Transcriber: Esin K
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Merhaba.
“Hiçbir şey ölmez, her şey yaşar.”
İnsanlık tarihinin ilk yazılı destanı olan
Gılgamış destanından bir alıntı.
Efsanevi kral, yüzyıllar öncesinden
bize tam olarak şöyle sesleniyor:
“Diyecekler ki,
mükemmel bir hayat sürdün.
Çalıştın, uğraştın, didindin
ve layık olduğun ölümü hak ettin.”
Hiçbir şeyden korkmadığım kadar
kadar ölümden korktum,
onu yenmek için dünyanın bir ucundan
diğer ucuna kadar seyahat ettim.
Ama başaramadım.
Geri döndüğümde artık ölümden
korkmaz olmuştum.
İşte hakikat budur.
Şayet yaşamımız boyunca
üzerimize düşen görevleri
layıkıyla yerine getirebiliyorsak
ölümden korkmamızın bir anlamı yok.
Öğrendiğim hakikatlerin en hakikati budur.
Ölüm mevcut değildir,
″hiçbir şey ölmez, her şey yaşar.”
Yüce Kral bize burada acaba gerçekten
bizim bildiğimiz anlamda ölümün
olmadığından mı bahsediyor,
yoksa onu diğer krallardan
daha üstün bir kral yapan,
başka bir anlama seviyesi,
başka bir farkındalık,
kabullenme ve olgunlaşmadan mı bahsediyor?
Bana göre Gılgamış tam
bir yüzleşme yaşıyor.
Ölümle ve ölümsüzlük ile yüzleşme.
Yaşarken ölen bir insan.
Nedir yaşarken ölen insanın
diğer insanlardan farkı?
Tabii ki olgunlaşabilmek.
Bunun da birinci kuralı
kendinizle ve gerçeklerle
açık yüreklilikle
korkmadan yüzleşebilmektir.
Bugünkü temanın sıfır noktası
olduğunu öğrendiğimde
‘sıfır’ hakkında bolca araştırma
yapma şansı buldum.
Sıfır için değersizliğin rakamı deniyordu.
Tabii insanoğlu sıfırı başka neyin
sembolü olarak kullanıyordu?
Hani bir kokusu var mıydı?
Rengi var mıydı?
Tek miydi, çift miydi?
Yeri neresiydi?
Bolca araştırma yaptım.
En beğendiğim yorumlardan bir tanesi
Hint mistisizminde yer alan, sıfırın
döngüselliğine, sürekliliğe,
yani aslında ölümsüzlüğe
yaptığı atıflardı.
Sıfır için hem yokluğun sembolü
hem de her şeyi kapsayanın sembolü
olduğundan bahsediliyordu.
Ne yalan söyleyeyim, ben de şu anki
hayatımı kurmadan önce
hem önceki çalışma hayatımda
hem de kavrayabildiğim tüm hayatı
koskocaman bir sıfır olarak görüyordum.
Ancak değersiz bir sıfır.
Ta ki bir gün,
tüm korkularımla yüzleşip ölümün dahi
ötesine geçebileceğime inanana kadar.
Size de bugün biraz bu maceranın
parça parça bölümlerinden
bahsetmeye çalışacağım.
Üniversite yıllarım dahil
finans sektöründe tam bir beyaz yakalı
olarak çalışıyordum.
Maaşım vardı, tatillerim belliydi.
Hani bir kariyer planımız,
hayalimiz vardı.
Sözüm ona bir gelecek garantimiz vardı.
Her şey bir düzen içerisinde
iyi gibi gidiyordu.
Yakın çevrem de bu gidişattan
çok da memnundu.
Ancak benim içimi sıkan,
kurcalayan, hani böyle
sizi yerinizden kaldırıp
başka bir yöne çevirecek
bir his, bir duygu oluşuyordu sürekli.
Bana göre kurumsal hayatmış gibiydi.
Benim kişiliğime, yaratıcılığıma,
değerlerime, kararlarıma
kıymet vermedikten sonra
o biraz önce bahsettiğim düzenin
içerisindeki kazançlar
bana pek bir anlamlı gelmiyordu.
Herkesin de çalışmak için gayret ettiği,
işe girmeye çabaladığı
kurumlarda çalıştım.
Hiç mütevazı de olmama gerek yok,
gayet de başarılı bir çalışanım aslında.
Pozisyonum gereği görebileceğim son
noktaları böyle görme, tanıma şansım oldu.
Hani bize kurdurulan o hayallerin
gerçek örneklerini gördüğümde,
o insanların çektiği sağlık problemi,
ailevi problemler, mutsuzluklar,
yaşantılar...
Oralara şahit olduğumda bende
bir gelecek kaygısı oluşmaya başladı.
Hani zaten ömrümüzün bir kısmını
buraya vermiştik,
birçok kısmını daha da
vermeye hazırlanıyorduk.
O son beni mutlu etmeyecekti.
Ve işten ayrılma kararı verdim 2-3 defa.
Tabii bu zor bir karar,
özellikle mecburiyeti olan insanlar
için çok daha zor bir karar.
İlk önce sizin yakın çevreniz
sizi koruma duygusuyla
sizi çok sevdikleri için,
tamamen iyi niyetli duygularla
sizin o konfor alanınızı bozmamanızı,
elinizdekileri kaybetmemenizi istiyorlar.
Ve sizin verdiğiniz bu kararı uygulamak
çok daha da zorlaşıyor aslında.
Ben bu kararı vermişken, henüz
uygulayamamışken
-bu 4-5 yıllık bir süreçtir benim için-
çevremdeki insanların da
ellerindeklerinden
avucundakilerinden olduklarını
görmeye başladım.
Yani günde on iki saatimi geçirdiğim
iş ortamında
gerçekten bir tane mutlu arkadaşım yoktu
ve herkes dert yanıyordu.
Bir gün şöyle bir düşünceye kapıldım,
hani ölüm nasıl bir şeydir diye
acaba düşünürken.
Ya dedim acaba şu çektiğimiz acılar,
şu yaşadığımız sıkıntılarla beraber o ömür
acaba ölümden daha mı az acı veriyor,
daha mı çok acı veriyor?
Ve farkettim ki aslında biz
o dönemde kaderimizi bizi hiç tanımayan,
bizimle ilgili belki hiç istediğimiz
bir son hazırlığı olmayan,
belki bir planı dahi olmayan
yabancıların eline bırakmıştık.
Bana göre yaşamına değer veren her insan
mutsuz olduğu, değer görmediği o yerden
uzaklaşmalıdır.
Veyahut orayı değiştirmek
için çabalamalıdır.
Ben de tam olarak böyle yaptım.
O içimdeki heyecanı ve enerjiyi
size tarif edemem.
Hiçbir planım yoktu, hiçbir
güvencem de yoktu.
En fazla iki hafta kadar dinlenmişimdir.
Ne yapacağımı düşünürken,
o zamanlar Türkiye’nin en büyük kuluçka
merkezlerinden bir tanesi
bir duyuru yayınladı.
O seneye ait startup seçmeleri başlamıştı.
Ben de şansım yaver gitti,
kurumsal hayattan, inovasyon ve
girişimcilikle ilgili tecrübelerim vardı.
Bir proje hazırladım, gönderdim, seçildim.
Yepyeni bir sıfır döngüsü yaratmıştım
aslında kendime.
Çok heyecanlıydım, yolum uzundu, zordu.
Hani bu kısmı biraz hızlı anlatayım
benim için de çok hızlı geçti gerçekten.
Ayda 7-8 defa İstanbul’a
gidip geliyordum Antalya’dan.
Bir ekip kurmuştum, teknoloji firmasıydı.
İlgili sektörün ilk 4 firmasıyla ön
görüşmeler başlanmıştı,
bütçelerimiz oluşmuştu.
Çok yoğun bir dönem içerisindeydim
ama mutluydum.
Antalya’dayken sokağa çıkma yasağı
başladı çünkü pandemi başlamıştı.
O geceyi hiç unutmam.
Benim bütün takvimim bozulmuştu
ve paydaşlarla olan görüşmelerimizde
işlerin kötüye gideceği,
duracağı söyleniyordu.
O gece düşündüm, dedim ki,
yani ya pandeminin
bitmesini bekleyecektim,
ki bu insanlık için belirsiz bir süreçti,
ya kendimi aşan bir mücadeleye girecektim,
pandemi ile mücadele ederek
bunu yapmaya çalışacaktım,
ya da çok kısa bir süre sonra tekrar sıfır
noktasında olduğumu kabul edip
kendime yeni bir döngü
yaratmam gerekiyordu.
Sabah uyandığımda eşime bu mobil
uygulama işini bırakıp
daha önceden de yine
hobi olarak ilgilendiğim
bağcılık ve şarap üretim işine gireceğimi
söylediğimde şaka yaptığımı sandı.
Çünkü bu bir öncekine göre çok daha
hızlı bir dümen çevirme idi,
çok daha hızlı bir karardı.
Ama bana göre zamanlaması mükemmeldi.
Hani onca o bir yıllık emek,
İstanbul’a gitmeler gelmeler,
harcanan paralar,
emekler, hepsi sıfırlanıyordu.
Ve öğrendim ki, aslında
bizim hayatta verdiğimiz kararlarla ilgili
illaki analitik ve mantıklı
bir zemine oturtturmak
veya birilerini ikna etmemize gerek yok.
Sizi aşkın bir güç var,
ihtiyacınız olduğu zaman
o sizin inancınıza ve samimiyetinize bağlı
size destek oluyor ve yardımcı oluyor.
Ben bu müdahaleyi
kesinlikle hissediyordum.
Sokağa çıkma yasağı varken,
tabii ben bu işi yine iki üç hafta
planladım kafamda neyi ne yapacağımı.
Hani bu tür değişimlerde ihtiyaçlar
çok önemlidir bana göre.
Yine kendimi şanslı hissediyordum,
hatta bunu bir
yetenek olarak adlandırırım.
Kendi ihtiyaçlarınızı kendiniz
belirleyebiliyorsanız
yolunuz daha pürüzsüz ilerler.
Tam olarak öyle yaptım.
Bir ölçeklendirme yaptım ve şaraphane
kurmaya karar verdim.
Zaten hobi olarak ilgilendiğim
küçük bir bağım vardı.
Ve Sagawin Şarapçılık’ı kurdum.
Tabii o zamanlar bu isim yok.
‘Saga’ İngilizcede destan,
mitolojik hikaye anlamına gelir.
Ben de çocukluğumdan beri
bu tür tarih, felsefe, mitoloji işlerine
biraz hevesliyim.
Babamın tavsiyesiyle ‘saga’ kelimesini
kullanmak istedik.
Ve yine biliyorum ki Anadolu,
bizim kültürümüz, bu topraklar,
Tarih boyunca üzüme ve şaraba
hep ev sahipliği yapmıştır.
Ve yine biliyorum ki
üzüm ve şarap da her zaman
insanın iyi ve kötü zamanlarında
şarapla birlikte eşlik etmiştir.
Hani dedik ki bir şarap,
bir destan mottomuz olsun
ve bu topraklardan kendi yağımızda
kavrulan yeni bir marka niye yaratmayalım?
Ölçeklendirme benim her zaman
en büyük gücüm olmuştu.
Bizimkisi böyle çok sermaye isteyen,
kendimizi güvence altına aldığımız,
arkamızda başka güçlerin
olduğu bir iş değildi.
Tam tersi emek yoğun bir iş.
Hiç çalışanımız yok.
Bu işi yaparken yani yeri geldi
boya yaptım,
yeri geldi çatı tamir ettim,
yeri geldi arkadaşlarımla duvar ördük,
yeri geldi kuzenlerimle saat geceleri
ikilere üçlere kadar çalıştık.
Ve bir şekilde bunu hayata geçirdik.
En çok nerede zorlandım derseniz,
bu işe karar verdiğimde ve yaparken
dünyanın bir yarısı bana bu işin neden
olmayacağını anlatıyordu.
Çünkü bizim sektörümüzde bir önyargı
vardır, klişeler vardır.
Yüz yıllık, elli yıllık bağlar yoksa,
dededen, atadan, babadan kalan bir
şaraphane, bir marka yoksa
bu iş gitmez, olmaz.
Hani sanki onların hiç sıfır
noktası yokmuş gibi.
Diğer yarısı da daha mühendis zekasıyla
daha endüstriyel bir bakış açısıyla,
bu işi nasıl daha verimli yapabilirsin,
bu ölçekte bu iş tutmaz,
nasıl daha büyütebilirsin, nasıl daha
çok para kazanabilirsin bunu anlatıyordu.
Gerçekten en çok bu görüşleri
dinlerken zorlandım.
Çünkü benim tek bir stratejim vardı:
Elimdeki imkanlarla en iyi
şarabı sunabilmek.
Şu an üçüncü senemizdeyiz.
Üçüncü hasatımızı tamamladık.
Yine alışık olmadığım bir sektörde,
aslında bir dünyada,
çok da alışık olduğum
polemiklerle yaşıyorum.
Yani daha önceki yaşantımda olan hırs,
rekabet, kavga, iyilik, paylaşmak,
dostluk, yardımlaşma,
her şey aynı.
Tek bir fark var:
Ben istemediğim hiçbir şeye maruz
kalmak zorunda değilim artık.
Ve biliyorum ki
insanı ölümsüz kılacak şey,
onun bu dünyaya bırakacağı eserdir
o ve bu eser de
onun yaşamı ve karakteridir.
Ve bu yüzden,
bu da bizim elimizde olduğu için
hiçbir zaman sıfır noktası yaratmaktan
ve sıfıra ulaşmaktan korkmuyorum.
Ben de Gılgamış gibi “hiçbir şey ölmez,
her şeyi yaşar” diyorum.
Teşekkür ederim.